hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll if any of you
have read the big picture my most recent
book you know that one of the things we
have to think about if we're natural
ists trying to come to terms with the
world of our experience is the
phenomenon of consciousness actually
most of you probably know that even if
you haven't read that book it's a pretty
well-known fact the question of course
is what is demanded of us by the fact of
consciousness can we simply hope to
explain consciousness using the same
tools we explained other things with
atoms and particles moving according to
the laws of physics according to the
standard model and the core theory or do
we need something else
somehow that helps us explain what
consciousness is and how it came about
so I'm someone who thinks we don't need
anything else I think it's just
understanding the motion and
interactions of physical stuff from
which consciousness emerges as a
higher-level phenomenon our guest today
is David Chalmers who is probably the
most well known and respectable
representative of the other side the
people who think that you need something
beyond just the laws of physics as we
currently know them to account for
consciousness David is the philosopher
who coined at the term the hard problem
of consciousness the idea being that the
easy problems are you know how you look
at things and why you react in certain
ways how you do math problems in your
head the hard problem being our personal
experience what it is like to be you or
me rather than somebody else the first
person's subjective experience that's
the hard problem and someone like me
things oh yeah what will get there it's
just a matter of words and understanding
and philosophy someone like David thinks
we need a real change in our underlying
way of looking at the world so he
describes himself as a naturalist
someone who believes in you know just
the natural world no supernatural world
not a duelist who thinks it's a
disembodied mind or anything like that
but he's not a physicalist he thinks
that the natural world has not only
natural properties not only physical
properties but mental properties as well
so I would I would characterize him as
convinced of the problem but he's not
wedded to any particular answer David
Chalmers is a philosopher who everyone
respects even if they don't agree with
him he said the light to talk to
because he is very open-minded about
considering different things like I said
he's convinced of this problem but when
it comes to solving the problem he will
propose solutions but he won't take them
to dogmatically he will change his mind
when good arguments comes along there's
a great person to talk to about this
very very important problem for natural
ists when they tried to confront how to
understand what it means to be a human
being and where consciousness comes from
also david has developed a recent
interest in the simulation hypothesis
the idea that maybe we could all be
living in a simulation running on a
computer owned by a very very advanced
civilization in a completely different
reality so we'll talk about the hard
problem of consciousness we'll talk
about various philosophical issues and
you know I won't pin him down on
anything I'm not trying to argue with
him my point here is not to convince
David Chalmers in real-time that he's
wrong but rather to let you the
listeners hear what his perspective is
on these issues and then hear what my
perspective is on these issues and
decide for yourself maybe you will
change your mind either right now or
sometime down the road so this is a fun
conversation I'm sure you'll like it and
let's go
[Music]
Dave telomers welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks it's great to be here so
I've discovered in my brief history of
having philosophers on the podcast that
there's a lot to say that we have a lot
of ground to cover I know that you
especially have all sorts of interests
let's just jump right into the
crowd-pleasing things that we can talk
about you're one of the world's experts
on the philosophy of consciousness you I
believe were the one who coined the
phrase the hard problem of consciousness
so how would you define what the hard
problem is the hard problem of
consciousness is the problem of
explaining how physical processes in the
brain somehow give rise to subjective
experience so when you think about the
mind there's not a whole lot of things
that need to be explained some of them
involve our sophisticated behavior all
the things we can do we can get around
we can walk we can talk we can
communicate with each other we can solve
scientific problems but a lot of that is
of a level of sophisticated behavioral
capacities things we can do it when it
comes to explaining behavior we've got a
pretty good bead on how to explain it in
principle at least you find a circuit in
the brain complex neural system which
may be perform some computations
produces some outputs generates the
behavior then in principle you've got an
explanation may take a century or two to
work out the details but that's roughly
the standard model in cognitive science
and you've wrapped this together is the
easy problem yeah so this is what 20
years ago I call the easy problem
slightly tongue-in-cheek of of the mind
and of consciousness in particular
roughly referring to these behavioral
problems yeah nobody thinks they're easy
in any ordinary sense sense in which
they're easy is that we know that we've
got a paradigm for explaining them find
a neural mechanism or a computational
mechanism that's the kind of thing that
could produce that behavior in principle
find the right one till the right story
you'll
and explanation but when it comes to
consciousness it's a subjective
experience it looks as if that method
doesn't so obviously apply I mean there
are some aspects of consciousness which
are roughly speaking behavioral or
functional you could use the word
consciousness for the difference between
being awake and responsive
for example versus being asleep or for
maybe just for the ability to talk about
certain things I can talk about the fact
that hey there's Sean Carroll there are
some books over there and I'm hearing my
voice and those are some reports
explaining those reports might also be
an easy problem but the really
distinctive problem of consciousness is
posed not via the behavioral parts but
by the subjective experience by how it
feels from the inside to be a conscious
being I'm seeing you right now I have a
visual image of colors and shapes that
are sort of present to me as an element
in the inner movie of the mind I'm
hearing my voice I'm filling my body
I've got a stream of thoughts running
through my head and the hub and this is
what philosophers called consciousness
or subjective experience and it's I take
it to be one of the fundamental facts
about ourselves that we have this kind
of subjective experience then the
question is how do you explain it and
the reason why we call it the heart
problem is it looks like the standard
method of just explaining behaviors and
explaining the things we do doesn't
quite come to grips with the question of
why is there subjective experience it
seems you could explain all of these
things we do the walking the talking the
reports the reasoning and so why doesn't
all that go on in the dark why do we
need subjective experience that's the
hard problem so sometimes I hear it
glossed as the question of what it is
like to be a subjective agent to be a
person that's a good definition of
consciousness actually first put forward
or at least made famous by my colleague
Tom Nagel he
at NYU in a article back in 1974 called
what is it like to be a bat and his
thought was well we don't know what it's
like to be a bat we don't know what
about subjective experience is like you
know it's got this weird sonar
perceptual capacity which doesn't really
correspond directly to anything that
humans have but presumably there is
something it's like to be a bat about is
conscious
so most people would say on the other
hand there's nothing it's like to be a
glass of water say if that's right then
a glass of water is not conscious so
that this what it's like way of speaking
way of speaking is a good way at least
of serving as an initial intuition pump
for what is the basic difference we're
getting at between systems which are
conscious and systems which are not and
the other word that is sometimes invoked
in this context is qualia the
experiences that we have like there's
one thing that is it is to see the color
red and a separate thing if I get a
right to have the experience of the
redness of red yeah this word qualia
might senses it's got a little bit of
not a favor over the last say 20 odd
years but maybe 20 years ago you heard a
lot of people speaking of qualia as a
word for the the sensory qualities that
you come across in experience in the
paradigm addict ones would be the
experience of red versus the experience
of green you know you can reach all this
familiar questions about this how do I
know that my experience of the things we
call red is the same maybe it's the same
as the experience you have when you
you're confronted with the things we
call green you know maybe your internal
experiences or are swapped with respect
to mine and people call that inverted
qualia that would be a your red is my
green or pain would be another example
of a the singular in Latin is quietly
right now the feeling of pain would be a
would be a quiet I'm not sure that these
qualities are all there is though to
consciousness and maybe that's one
reason why it's gone out of favor
there's also an experience to thinking
reasoning and to feeling this much
harder to pin down in terms of sensory
qualities but they're still you might
think something that's like to think
and to reason even though it's not the
same as what it's like to sense I want
to just for a little bit talk about this
question of whether or not you and I
have the same experience when we see the
color red I'm not sure I know what that
could possibly mean for it to be either
the same experience or a different
experience I mean one is going on in my
head one is going on in your head
in what sense could they be the same but
maybe when I say that it's just a
reflection of the fact that there's a
hard problem well we know some people
for example have to get much easier case
some people are color blind right they
can't they don't even make a distinction
between red and green they're red green
you know most people have a red green
access for color vision and a blue
yellow access and something like a
brightness access but some people do to
do to you know things going wrong in
their retinal mechanisms don't even make
the distinction between red and green so
I can go friends who are red-green
colorblind I'm often asking you know
what is it like to be you is it like you
to see everything in shades of blue and
yellow and you don't get the reds and
greens or is it something different
entirely but we know is that what it's
like to be them can't be the same as
what it's like to be us because for
example reds and greens which are
different for us are the same for them
so there's got to be some difference
between us as a matter of logic my red
can't be the same as their red and my
green can't be the same as if my red was
the same as their red and my green was
the same as their green and their red
was the same we know their red is the
same as their green then my red couldn't
be different from my green but lives as
a matter of logic there has to be some
difference there but isn't so one way
out is just well everybody who is
different from everybody else their
experiences are different I guess the
question then is in what sense could
they ever be the same what is it what is
the meaningfulness and I can imagine
some kind of operational sameness right
like you say the word red when you see
the word read in that behavioral sense
but that's exactly what you don't want
to count yeah so I guess intuitively
most people think that we can you know
at least grasp the idea that my red is
the same as your red and then it's an
empirical open question whether they are
in fact exactly the same I mean you're
saying well it is unfair how you could
operationalize
that mattered now you might say I'm a
scientist I want an operational test on
the other hand I'm a philosopher and I'm
very skeptical of the idea that you want
you can operationalize everything that
you know hypothesis has got to be
operationalize about to be to be
meaningful I mean it was a movement in
philosophy in the first part of the 20th
century logical positivism or logical
empiricism where they said the only
meaningful hypotheses are the ones we
can we can test and for various reasons
that turned out to have a lot of
problems not least because this very
this very philosophical hypothesis of
verification ISM turned out not to be
one that you could test so they'd say
there's a renaissance of logical
positivism on philosophy Twitter these
days I wasn't right yeah Rudolf Carnap
who was one of the great logical
positivist is one of my one of my heroes
only I read all whole book called
constructing the world that was partly
partly based around some of his ideas
numberless verification ISM is not one
of the ones okay and I think when it
comes to consciousness in particular
we're dealing with something essentially
subjective yeah I know I'm conscious not
because I measured my behavior or
anybody else's behavior it's because
it's something I experienced directly
from the first-person point of view I
think you're probably conscious but you
know it's not as if I can give a
straight out operational definition of
it if you say you were conscious then
you're conscious it's like who's to say
that doesn't most people think that
doesn't absolutely settle the question
maybe we'd come up with an AI that says
it's conscious and okay well that would
be very interesting but would it settle
the question of whether it's having
subjective experience probably not well
so Alan Turing tried right the Turing
test was supposed to be a way to judge
what's conscious from what's not what
are your feelings about the success of
that program I think it's not a bad I
mean of course no no machine right now
is remotely close to passing that you're
amazing with the Turing test is yeah so
the Turing test is the idea that it's
basically a test to see whether a
machine can behave in a manner
indistinguishable from a normal human
being at least in a verbal conversation
over say hi text messaging and and the
like ensuring thought that eventually
we'll have machines that pass this test
that is they're indistinguishable from
say another human interlocutor over
hours of conversational testing then he
didn't say at that point then machines
can think what he said was at that point
the question of whether machines can
think becomes basically meaningless
right and I provided an operational
definition to substitute for it so once
they passed this test he says that's
good enough for me
yeah he talked to the paper about the
consciousness objection you might say
that it's just mimicking consciousness
but not really conscious and he's as I
recall his responses well who cares I
can't possibly test that therefore it's
not meaningful but it turns out the
consciousness is one of the things that
we value a it's one of the central
properties about me of our minds and to
many of us think it's what actually
gives our minds gives our lives meaning
and value if we weren't conscious if we
didn't have subjective experience then
we basically just be you know automata
for whom nothing has any meaning or
value so I think when it comes to the
question once we develop more and more
sophisticated a is the question of
whether they're conscious is going to be
absolutely central to how we treat them
to whether they have moral status
whether we should you know care whether
they continue to live or die whether
they get rights and so on I think many
people think if they're not having
subjective experiences and they're
basically machines that we can treat the
way we can we treat machines but if
they're having conscious experiences
like how there would be horrific to
treat them the way we currently treat
machines so yeah I mean if you just
simply operationalize all those
questions and there's a danger I think
that you lose the things which are
really the things that we really care
about and just so we can get our sort of
background assumptions on the table here
for the most part neither you or I are
coming from a strictly dualist
perspective we're not trying to explain
consciousness in terms of a Descartes
Ian disembodied immaterial mind that is
a separate substance right I mean we
want to at least as the as the first
hypothesis say that you and I are made
of atoms we're obeying the laws of
physics and the consciousness is somehow
related to that but not an entirely
separate category interacting with us is
that right so fair yeah there's
different kinds and different degrees of
dualism I mean my background is very
much in mathematics and computer science
and physics and all of my instincts my
first instincts are materialist to try
to explain everything in terms of
ultimately in terms of the processes of
physics and we explain yeah biology in
terms of chemistry and chemistry in
terms of physics and this is a wonderful
great chain of great chain of
explanation but I do think when it comes
to consciousness this is that the one
place where that great chain of
explanation seems to break down roughly
because when it comes to biology and
chemistry and all these other fields the
things that need exponent explaining are
all basically these easy problems of
structure and dynamics and ultimately
the behaviors of these systems when it
comes to consciousness we seem to have
something different that needs
explaining and I think that the standard
kinds of explanations say that you get
out of physics derived Sciences physics
chemistry biology neuroscience and so on
just ultimately won't add up to an
explanation of subjective experience
because it always leaves open this
further question why is all that
sophisticated processing accompanied by
consciousness by a subjective experience
that doesn't mean though we suddenly
need to say it's all properties of say a
soul or some religious thing which has
existed since the beginning of time and
will go on to continue after our death
people sometimes call that substance
dualism maybe there's a whole separate
substance that's the mental substance
and somehow interact connects up with
our physical bodies and interact with it
yoga that view is much harder to check
to connect to a scientific view of the
world but the direction I end up going
is what people sometimes call property
dualism the idea that there are some
extra properties of things in the
universe I mean this is something we're
used to in physics already people of
maybe around the time of Maxwell we had
a we had physical theories that took
space and time and mass as fundamental
and then Maxwell wanted to explain
electromagnetism and there was a
trying to explain them in terms of space
and time and mass so now turns out it
didn't quite work he couldn't explain it
mechanically and eventually we entered
that positing charge as a fundamental
property and some new laws governing
governing electromagnetic phenomena and
that was just an extra property right in
a scientific picture of the world so I'm
inclined to think that something not
exactly analogous to that but at least
analogous to that in some respects is
what we have to do with consciousness as
well basically explanations in terms of
space and time and mass in charge and
whatever the fundamentals are in physics
these days are not going to add up to an
explanation of consciousness so we need
another fundamental property right there
as well and you know one working
hypothesis is let's take consciousness
as an irreducible element of the world
and then see if we can come up with a
scientific explanation of it good I
think this is I mean we should
absolutely be open to that I don't go
down that road myself I don't find it
very convincing but maybe you know in
the next 45 minutes you'll convince me
so I would I do want to get there but
let's play a little bit more groundwork
first so one of the things that a lot of
the statements I'm going to be making
over the course of the chat are of the
form I think this is right correct
meaning long so I think one of the
things that makes the hard problem hard
is just the fact that you can't even
imagine looking at neurons doing
something and saying AHA that explains
it is that fair to say yeah I would say
that what we when you appeal to neural
activity and explaining phenomena
there's a paradigm attak way that works
we see how those neurons serve as a
mechanism for performing some function
ultimately generating some behavior that
is the paradigm addict appeal to to to
neurobiology in explanation and just
looks like any explanation of that form
is not gonna add up to an explanation of
consciousness it explains the wrong
thing it will explain behavior but those
were the easy problems explaining
consciousness was something distinct
that's the hard problem so you think
that even if and this were very far away
from this but even if neuroscientists
got to the point where for every time
that a person was doing something we
would all recognize as having a
conscious experience even if it was
silent you know experiencing the redness
of red they could point to exactly the
same neural activity going on in the
brain you would say yes but this still
doesn't explain my subjective experience
yeah that's in fact a very very
important research program going on
right now in neuroscience and people
call it the program of finding neural
correlates of consciousness the NCC
for short and we're trying to find the
NCC that neural system or systems is
active precisely when you're conscious
and that correlates perfectly with
consciousness which is a very very
important research program but it's
really as it stands a program for
correlation not for explanation so we
could know that say when a certain
special kind of neuron fires in a
certain pattern that that neural pattern
always goes along with consciousness but
then the next question then is why
explain that fact why is it that this
pattern gives you consciousness and as
it stands nothing that we get out of the
neural correlates of consciousness
program in neuroscience comes close to
explaining that matter and I think a lot
of people as they start to think about
this thing
we basically need some further
fundamental principle that connects the
neural correlate of consciousness with
the consciousness itself I mean
Giulio Tononi has developed a theory
integrated information theory where he
says consciousness goes along with a
certain mathematical measure of the
integration of information that he calls
Phi and the more fire you have the more
consciousness you have and Phi is a
mathematically and physically a
respectable quantity very hard to
measure but in principle but you can die
it could be measured I mean there's
questions about whether it's actually
well defined in terms of the details of
physics and physical systems but it's at
least you know halfway to being
something right something definable but
even if even if he's right that Phi this
informational property of the brain
correlates perfectly with consciousness
they still the question of why why prime
officially it looks like you could have
had a universe with all of this
integration of information going on and
no consciousness at all and yet
in our universe there's consciousness
how do we explain that fact well I think
that's what I regard as the scientific
thing to do at this point to say okay
well we bought in science we boil
everything down to fundamental
principles and fundamental laws and if
we need to postulate a fundamental law
the Kinect's a fire with consciousness
then that's great and then that will
maybe that's gonna end up being the best
we can do just as in say and in physics
you always end up with some fundamental
laws whether it's a principle of
gravitation or a grand unified theory
that unifies all these different forces
you still end up with some fundamental
principles and you don't explain them
further something has to be taken as
basic and the question of course we want
to minimize our fundamental principles
and minimize our fundamental properties
as far as we can but Occam's razor says
don't multiply entities without
necessity if you know and then there's
necessity Maxwell had necessity and if
I'm right there's necessity in this case
too and you hinted at you you sort of
alluded to an idea that is one of your
most famous philosophical thought
experiments just there where you say you
can imagine a system with whatever file
you want but we wouldn't call it
conscious so you take this idea to the
extreme and say there can be something
that looks and acts just like a person
but doesn't have consciousness so this
is the philosophers thought experiment
of the zombie the philosopher zombie is
somewhat different from the ones you
find in Hollywood movies are in you know
Haitian Vodou culture the ones in Voodoo
culture as far as I can tell or mostly
beings that have been given some kind of
point people have been given some kind
of poison and somehow seem to be lacking
autonomy volition a certain kind of free
will the ones in Hollywood movies are
beings which were a lot like us but
they're dead and animated and they
weren't brains the Philosopher's zombie
is a creature which is exactly like us
functionally and maybe physically that
isn't conscious now it's very important
to say nobody certainly not me
it's arguing that zombies actually exist
that for example some human beings
around us or zombies actually I did once
meet a philosopher and
in Dublin who is very concerned that
quite a lot of philosophers actually
we're zombies they weren't they weren't
conscious at all and I was I was a
little bit insulted by this he seemed to
be worried about me a lot yeah yeah he
took me to lunch and he asked me a whole
lot of questions about about
consciousness energy you know and at the
end he said okay you pass I think I
think you're conscious okay but a zombie
could also pass right I mean I think so
so is it right to say that a zombie yeah
I don't think it'd be we let you finish
your definition you know but zombie will
be behaviorally the same but yeah
behaviorally the same but no conscious
experience there's nothing it's like to
be a zombie maybe a good bit of work
after this is by thinking about say some
sophisticated artificial intelligence
system that produces lots of intelligent
responses maybe it talks to you maybe an
extension of you know Alexa or Siri who
carries on a very sophisticated
conversation with us most of us are not
inclined to think that say Alexa and
Siri as they stand our conscious that
they're having subjective experiences
okay now put Alexa in a body like like
Sofia the robot is a robot that's out
there with a very sophisticated
conversational system make her smart her
and and smart her then there's at least
an open question is she going to be
conscious and we could make make sense
of the hypothesis that she's conscious
we can also make sense of the hypothesis
that there's not that she's not the
extreme case is gonna be a complete
physical and functional duplicate of a
human being with all the brain
processing intact all of the behavior
maybe even a complete physical duplicate
of Sean Carroll and I think I can make
sense of the hypothesis when I talk to
you that there be such a being who's not
conscious zombie Sean Carroll now I'm
very confidently or not
zombie Sean Carol I think most human
beings are enough like me that they're
they're gonna be conscious but the point
is at least seems logically possible it
seems there's no contradiction in the
idea of a being physically just like you
without consciousness and that's just
one way of getting
at the idea that somehow well where you
do have consciousness then something
special on extra has to be going on
something you could just put the hard
problem of consciousness as the problem
of why why aren't we zombies right what
differentiates us from zombies and with
some trepidation let me ask the question
how the difference between possible and
conceivable comes into the zombie
argument yeah I mean philosophers like
to talk about possible worlds what goes
on in different possible worlds and you
know there's a possible world where
Hillary Clinton won the election and
2016 and there are possible worlds where
the Second World War never happened
these are all maybe so terribly distinct
possible worlds they might for example
share roughly the same laws of physics
as ice maybe small differences in the in
the initial conditions some of us think
we can also make sense of world with
different laws of physics and different
laws of nature maybe there are classical
possible worlds maybe there are possible
worlds that are 2-dimensional like
Conway's Game of Life with just bits
fluttering on a surface governed by by
uh by simple rules so yeah there are
very distant possible worlds with very
different laws of nature and the
broadest class is maybe something like
the logically possible world corresponds
roughly to what we can conceive of or
what we can imagine we maybe there are
even worlds we can't imagine like world
where 2+2 is 5 that's getting a bit too
far even forever things really start to
go haywire around that point but as long
as we don't have contradictions then we
can at least entertain possible world so
I'm inclined to think the zombie
hypothesis looks to me perfectly
coherent and perfectly conceivable there
is a universe which is physically
identical to ours in which nobody has
subjective experience it's a that's not
an entire zombie universe if you like
conscious experience never flickers into
existence there's just a whole bunch of
sophisticated behavior I don't think I'm
universes like that but it seems to make
sense and one way to pose the hard
problem is saying what differentiates
our world from that world right so where
I come down here is I don't think that
zombozo conceivable
and I'm very happy to be talked out of
this because I think it I I talked to
you a couple years ago before I wrote
the big picture and I was not quite as
sharp and my thoughts about this so like
you just said we could imagine a literal
physical copy in front of our world so
that includes all the people in it all
the atoms that they're made of and and
you do think that as far as we know the
atoms in my body just obey the laws of
physics as we know them right so I would
in that world I would be here in that
world but without consciousness without
experience I would be here I'd be a
zombie but I would be acting and saying
exactly the same thing as I'm acting and
saying it was that right yeah okay and
so if you in that world were to ask me
if I were conscious I would say yes
yeah and presumably there is a sensible
way in which I could say it I say yes
because I believe it to be true is that
fair yeah it's a complicated issue
whether zombies actually believe
anything don't be analogues of beliefs
at the at the very least so in I mean
the most basic way to put it then is how
can I be sure that I'm not a zombie if
all the things that I say and do are
exactly what a zombie would say and do
well I think this is a very good
argument that I can't be sure that you
are not a zombie because all I have
access to with respect to you is you
know your behavior and your functioning
right and so on and none of that none of
that seems to absolutely differentiate
you from a zombie I think the first
person case is different because in the
first person case I'm conscious I know
that I'm conscious I know that more
directly that I know of anything else I
mean Descartes said you know way back in
the 1640s this is the the one thing I
can be certain of I can doubt everything
about the external world I could even I
can doubt there's a table here I can
doubt there's a body there's one thing I
can't doubt that's what I'm thinking or
I think he could even better I said that
I'm conscious I think therefore I am so
therefore I don't I can't doubt my own
existence so I would take it just I
think it's natural to take consciousness
is our primary epistemic datum so
whatever you say about zombies and so on
I know that I'm not
because I know that I'm conscious but I
think that my worry about exactly that
is that so
like you said my argument certainly
would make you wonder whether I am
conscious I think it also makes me
wonder whether I'm conscious because I
think that the zombie me would because
the zombie me would behave in exactly
the same way it includes you know
writing all the bad poetry I wrote in
high school and you know crying at
movies at wall-e and so forth and you
know petting my cats like all of these
things the zombie would do in exactly
the same way that I do if you ask that
zombie me are you conscious it would say
yes and here's why we give you reasons I
don't see how I can be sure that I'm not
that zombie mm-hmm I think to be fair
this is your you put your finger on I
think the weakest spot for the for the
zombie hypothesis and for ideas that
come from it in my first book the
conscious mind came out about 20 years
ago I had a whole chapter on this that I
called the paradox of phenomenal
judgment that basically stems from the
fact that my zombie twin in that
universe next door is going around doing
exactly the same things that I'm doing
and saying the same things that I'm
saying and even writing a word for a
word identical book called the conscious
mind yeah arguing that arguing that
consciousness is irreducible to two
physical processes and I disable yeah
well and that's I mean you know a lot of
strange things go on in possible world
you shouldn't take them too too
seriously but I'd say that yeah in the
zombie universe the right view is what
philosophers call a limit of ism that
there is no such thing as consciousness
the zombie is in fact making a mistake I
think there is a there is a respectable
program about consciousness in our world
that says we're basically in the
situation of the zombie and lately just
so ever last two or three years actually
there's been a bit of an upsurge of
people really thinking seriously about
this view which has come to be known as
illusionism okay the idea that
consciousness is some kind of internal
introspective illusion after all figure
out what's going on with the zombie
their zombie thinks it has special
properties of consciousness but it
doesn't all those dark inside so then
see that's
how situation it's like it seems to us
do we have all these special properties
those qualia those sensory experiences
Bruno all is in a way dark inside for us
as well but there's just a very strong
introspective mechanism that makes us
think we have these special properties
that's illusionism now yeah most people
find it impossible to believe the
consciousness is an illusion in that way
on the other hand the view does have the
advantage of predicting that you would
find it impossible to believe if it's if
it's a good enough mechanism it makes
you focus on this so actually lately
I've been thinking about this a lot and
I wrote an article called the meta
problem of consciousness has just come
out in the journal of consciousness
studies the hard problem of
consciousness is why are we conscious
how the physical processes give rise to
consciousness the meta problem of
consciousness is why do we think we're
conscious and why do we think there's a
problem of consciousness and the great
thing about the meta problem is remember
the hard prop the easy problems were
about behavior the hard problems about
experience
well the meta problem is a problem
ultimately about behavior it's about the
things we say things we do why do I go
why don't people go around writing books
about this why do they say I'm conscious
I'm feeling the pain why do they say I
have these properties that are hard to
explain and functional terms that's a
behavioral problem that's an easy
problem maybe ultimately there'll be a
mechanistic explanation of that and that
would have caused big potential grist
for the illusionists mill once you have
the mechanisms that explain what we say
all these things in physical terms
you could then try and turn that round
it's an explanation of of you can call
that solution to the meta problem an
explanation of the illusion of
consciousness some people will still
find it unbelievable but again the view
predicts that and if I wanted to know
why I feel puzzled by the hard problem
of consciousness is that the meta matter
problem I think that maybe that's still
the it maybe that's still the metaphor I
guess why why do you find consciousness
puzzling is certainly one central aspect
to the meta problem there are all these
things that we seem to feel and say my
red could be your green right
I can imagine zombies consciousness
seems non-physical those
all behaviors explain those behaviors
and maybe you've explained at least the
the higher-order judgments about
consciousness now my own view is that
that even that wouldn't add up to an
explanation of consciousness but I think
at the very least understanding that
those mechanisms might tell us something
very very interesting about the basis of
consciousness so I've been recommending
this as a research program a neutral
research program for everyone
philosophers science it's not presuming
any conclusion about what the answer
will be exactly didn't you didn't be
materialist you needn't be Julis you
didn't be illusionists you didn't be you
know this is just a basically an
empirical research program of here are
some facts about human behavior let's
try and explain them furthermore
philosophers psychologists
neuroscientists AI researchers could all
the principal get in on this and I think
that's gradually building I mean there's
already going to be a target article a
symposium in Journal of consciousness
studies with a whole bunch of people
from all those fields getting in on it
so I'm hoping this at least turns out to
be a productive way to come with the
question of course it won't be neutral
forever eventually we'll have some stuff
and then that you know some results and
some mechanisms and then the argument
will continue to rage between people who
think the whole thing's an illusion and
the whole thing is real we should say
though that aside from eliminative ism
in illusionism which are fairly sort of
hardcore on one side or forms of dualism
which could be on the other side there
is this kind of emergent position that
one can take is what I want to take in
the big picture and so forth which is
physicalist and materialist at the
bottom but doesn't say that there are
four things like consciousness and our
subjective experiences don't exist or
our illusions they are higher-order
phenomena like tables and chairs you
know there are categories that we invent
to help us organize our experience of
the world yeah you know my view is that
emergence is a sometimes used as kind of
a magic word to make us feel good about
things that we don't understand how do
you get from this to this oh it's it's
submergent emerging you know what really
do you mean by emergent Africa I wrote
an article on emergence where I
distinguished weak emergence from strong
emergence weak emergence is basically
the kind you
from you know low-level structure
dynamics explaining higher-level
structure dynamics of behavior of a
complex system traffic flows in a city
the dynamics of a hurricane I mean you
get all kinds of strange and surprising
and cool phenomena emerging at the
higher level but still it's ultimately
once you understand the low-level
mechanisms well enough the high-level
ones just follow transparently it's just
low-level structure giving you high
level structure according to the
following of certain simple low-level
rule who put it on a computer and
simulate exactly but when it comes to
consciousness it looks like well when it
comes to the easy problems of
consciousness those may well turn out to
be emergent in just this way that may
turn out to be low-level structural
functional mechanisms that produce these
reports and these behaviors and lead to
systems sometimes being awake and no one
would be surprised if these were weakly
emergent in that way but none of that
seems to add up to an explanation of
subjective experience which just looks
like something fundamentally new this is
philosophers sometimes talking about
emergence you know in a different way is
strong emergence which actually involves
something fundamentally new emerging via
new fundamental laws maybe there's a
fundamental law that's saying says when
you get this information being
integrated then you get consciousness I
think consciousness may be emergent in
that sense but that's not a sense that
ought to help the materialist I think if
you want consciousness to be emergent in
a sense that helps the materialist you
have to go for a weak emergence and
that's ultimately going to require
reducing the hard problem to an easy
problem so I won't I think everyone has
to make hard choices here and I don't
wanna let you off the hook of us saying
that's all ultimately gonna be the brain
and a bunch of emergence there's a
respectable materialist research program
here but it has to involve ultimately
turning the hard problem all you're
gonna get out of physics is ultimately
more and more structure and dynamics and
functioning and so on so for that to
turn into an explanation of
consciousness you need to find some way
to deflate what needs explaining in the
case of consciousness ultimately to a
matter of behavior and a matter of
functioning and maybe say that extra
thing that seems to need explaining
that's an illusion and you know people
like damn damn it I respect
lately has tried to do this for years
for decades that's mean his research
program at the end of the day most
people look at what Dan has come up with
and they say no not good enough you
haven't explained consciousness if you
could do better than great
whereas so to move more in the direction
of what you're positively advocating for
at least I mean you've always been very
careful to positively advocate for not
that much because as you say a hard
problem we don't know the answers yet we
we don't need to move forward by sort of
insisting this might be there must be
the right answer so you've been open
minded but you're at least open-minded
about this property dualism that you
talked about and that sort of one
version of that leads us into pan
psychism so can you explain these two
concepts yeah so I'd say that I've
explored a number of different positive
views on consciousness what I haven't
done is committed to to any of them I
see various different interesting
possibilities each of which has has big
problems has big attractions but also
big problems to overcome so I've tried
to explore some of those one at a time
one of the possibilities is pent
psychism the idea that consciousness
goes right down to the bottom of the
natural order pen psychism my pan means
all psychic means mind so it's basically
saying everything has a mind taken
literally would imply that people have
Minds particles have minds but also
tables and numbers have minds so we have
to say have minds or can we just get
away with saying something like have
mental properties as well as physical
ones yeah we can makes you feel better
it might be a little bit better you have
experiences we could say there's
something it's like to be them well I
don't know I mean deed do we want to say
an electron has experiences well I think
pants psychism taken literally has that
consequence by the way most pants
artists don't say that tables or rocks
or numbers have minds but they're
typically that the biggest commitment is
to fundamental physical entities have a
mind so if you want to say now there's a
weaker view you might want to say
actually something just like to be an
electron electron doesn't have
experiences it merely has some proto
version of experience some predecessor
of experience maybe electrons are proto
conscious then there's a view called
proto psychism that could could maybe
seem a little bit less insane okay to
you I mean the trouble of course one of
the troubles with pan psychism is it
seems very counterintuitive because we
don't naturally think that electrons
have consciousness and there's not a
whole lot of direct evidence in favor of
it on the other hand you might say
there's also not a whole lot of direct
evidence against it it's not like we've
got any experimental evidence that
electrons are not conscious
well let me rather than harp on that
let's let me just try to figure out what
it would mean for electrons to have
minds or experiences or consciousness it
certainly can't mean another quantum
number in the physical sense right they
can't have you know happy electrons
inside electrons that would change much
of particle physics in in bad ways so is
it that the some kind of at the
phenomenalism do the do the happiness or
sadness if we want to call it that just
go along with the electron what it what
determines what the electron is feeling
the way I think the best option for a
pantheist here is yet you don't need a
whole bunch of extra new laws of physics
for the consciousness at the basis
rather it's consciousness that's
fundamentally playing the clausal role
for the physics that we know I mean it's
a point that's often remained about
about physics it was fundamentally the
science of physics is fundamentally
structural or mathematical everything is
basically explained by how it relates to
to other things maybe quantum mechanics
gets messy and and you know everything
else in contemporary physics gets even
Messier so let's just start with
classical physics that characterizes you
know particles with positions in space
and time but some mass with some forces
that operate on them what is mass in
classical physics well it's this thing
which is subject to the laws of
gravitation and the laws of motion and
that you know is involved in forces in a
certain weight nothing here tells us
what mass is in itself rather explains
mass by the way that you know particles
with mass interact with other particles
what its role with mass so it's it's all
a giant structure and physics has a
great job of characterizing this
structure and then you want to that
raises the question well what is what is
it what is the intrinsic nature
of mess well one thing someone might say
is I doesn't need to have an intrinsic
nature it's just a giant relational web
and that's a respectable view which I
think yeah some people think it doesn't
make sense
other people think it makes sense but
here's another possibility truck chiral
real this structural realism is what it
gets cold in contemporary philosophy of
science an ontological structural
realism
says that's all there is in the world a
giant web of relations right okay but
the other possibility
people sometimes become epistemological
structural realism but physics tells us
is the structure but there may be some
intrinsic nature's underlying the
structure as far as I could tell that's
a respectable possibility as well that
mass does have an intrinsic nature that
when two things with mass interact
they've got some intrinsic properties
that govern that interaction and of
course the pants are cast idea is to say
maybe that intrinsic property is
consciousness or experience or maybe
proto experience mind yeah it's our mind
lies at the bottom of you at this bottom
level serving as the intrinsic
properties that underlie physical
structure if that's the role of place we
don't suddenly need to revise physics
the structure of physics can stay
exactly as it was we're just gonna have
some intrinsic properties the ground
that structure then you might say well
now how is mind making a difference well
it's not like it's making a difference
by suddenly having new laws in the
picture for minds rather it's making a
difference by being the thing the
grounds the physical web anytime one
particles mass interacts with another
two particles say attract each other by
a gravitational force on this picture
it's ultimately going to be their mental
properties doing the work okay so you
are we're not saying again in this
picture which may or may not be right
but we're not saying that the mental
properties affect the physical behavior
of the electrons so a physicist I know
some personally might worry that this
isn't saying anything at all because
still everything the electrons do is
just governed by the laws of physics
because these mental properties don't
affect it but you're saying well that's
just the wrong way to ask the question
the kinds of things that are being
explained by this positing of a
mental character underlying everything
are not the behavior of the electrons
but something deeper and something that
kind of flowers once you get complex
organisms that we recognize as conscious
it does the experience affect the
behavior in one sense yes sir that was
hence no here's I mean it's certainly
true this is not going to be so exciting
for a current physicist in that all the
current physics can say the same physics
with the experience underneath it or
without it might think it's a good thing
we have all the excitement we need yet
if we had to if we had to revise physics
to then it would be a it would give rise
to all kinds of extra crazy complexities
that's said this is more of an
interpretation of current physics of
what's going on in the world underneath
current physics since ultimately saying
that what is doing the work in physics
at the bottom level is these intrinsic
properties of mind or consciousness the
fundamental laws you know which we think
of as laws say connecting mass and mass
or mass in motion or whatever ultimately
going to be laws connecting little bits
of experience in this structure from the
outside all we see is the structure let
me give it a mathematical description
and we call that the laws of physics and
it's great but in reality what's
underlying it you know we're used to the
idea that what underlies a physical
theory may involve more than what
actually gets that we see in
experimental results in on this
hypothesis what underlies that in
reality is a whole bunch of minds or
experiences pushing and pulling each
other is this wildly speculative of
course it is but is it ruled out by
anything we know I think not so I think
it's in a speculative vein it's at least
a philosophical view to take seriously
and it must be tempting to look toward
quantum mechanics for a place to
implement these kinds of ideas yeah
quantum mechanics is of course it's a
magnet for anyone who wants to find a
place for crazy properties of the mind
to interact with the earth in the
physical world because the quantum
mechanics is so ill understood then it
does have suggestive properties that
connect that may seem to connect to
observation or the mind I would actually
not connect combine quantum mechanics
and pan psychism
in the most in the most promising role
there are people who connect quantum
mechanics and pen sarcasm
somehow the right degree of quantum
mechanical holism somehow you can see
how those individual experiences might
add up to a big experience lately though
I've actually been thinking about
quantum mechanics in the context of a
different kind of view which is more a
kind of dualism with property dualism
with with properties of of consciousness
distinct from properties in physics but
somehow interacting with it if you're
going to be it not gonna be a pen
scientist and say consciousness is
present at the bottom level of physics
then consciousness has to be somehow the
property of consciousness has to be
separate from those other ones
space-time mass charge and that raises
the question now how does it interact
either you say it doesn't it's epi
phenomenal it does nothing well that's
kind of weird and consciousness has no
effect at all in the physical world yeah
or you say it has an effect on the
physical world then the question is how
on earth you reconcile that with physics
which doesn't seem on the face of it to
have any room for consciousness to play
that role and there is them but there is
of course this one I would say age-old
idea
can't be an age-old idea because quantum
mechanics has only been around for a
century or so but this one all the idea
that maybe there's at least one kind of
fairly traditional interpretation of
quantum mechanics where minds could play
a role in quantum mechanics mainly
namely via the process of observation
which collapses the quantum wave
function of course it's very
controversial but it is a very
traditional picture of quantum mechanics
there's two kinds of dynamics of the
quantum wave function there's
Schrodinger evolution the normal thing
and there's something weird which
happens on measurement and standard
quantum mechanics says make a
measurement the wavefunction collapses
and that's a different thing from
Schrodinger evolution now I'm of course
this immediately raises a million
questions like what on earth is
measurement and why should that might
get any special treatment that's the
quantum measurement problem and that's
many people run a mile at that point
saying oh I don't want minds to play a
role and physics let's try and do let's
try something else and they find
themselves in Everett style many will
quantum mechanics or bum style hidden
variables quantum mechanics or grw style
collapse quantum mechanics which doesn't
give give minds role unless all those
programs are great and very interesting
I'm not against them but I'm also
interested in a possibility which may
have been overlooked which is trying to
make rigorous sense of a more face value
interpretation of quantum mechanics
where there is something special that
takes place upon measurement now if your
average physicist well why can't we just
infer a strange to treat measurements as
fundamental because that would involve
treating the mind as fundamental and
that's not coming everyone wants to do
if on the other hand you're inclined to
think there's already reason to think
the mind involves something fundamental
and that consciousness is somehow a
fundamental element in nature then that
reason to reject the view will not be a
good reason to reject the view in the
question for me is just can we actually
make rigorous mathematical sense of the
idea that it's once consciousness comes
into the picture
that the wavefunction collapses is it
fair to associate this view with
something like idealism where you're
putting mind as the first thing that
creates reality all right maybe there's
an idealist version of this but I would
actually think of it as a version of
property dualism okay that is the
quantum wave function is real it's got
an existence it has nothing to do with
the mind the universe has an objective
wavefunction just as it might on say
Everett's style view is rather there's
this aspect of the dynamics of the
wavefunction which is affected by the
mind and under certain circumstances
physical systems will produce
consciousness under certain
circumstances that consciousness will
collapse the quantum wave function so
it's actually it's a Descartes thought
that you know the body affects the mind
and the mind affects the body that was
classic interactionist dualism think of
this as an updated version of Descartes
in a property dualism jewelers framework
you've got the quantum wave function
you've got some dynamics by which the
wave function affects consciousness you
got some laws it might be say something
like two Nonis integrated information
theory says when the wave function has a
integrated information then you get a
bit of consciousness and then he needs
some other bit of dynamics by which
consciousness can affect the
wavefunction the idea that I I was
working on this weather with Calvin
McQueen former former student of mine
who's now in in philosophy and physics
at Chapman University in in California
and the idea we started working with was
there's something special about
consciousness or maybe about the
physical correlates of consciousness so
that it resists quantum superposition
everything in the world mass and charge
can most properties can evolve into a
quantum superpositions but maybe there
are some special properties that resist
quantum superpositions maybe they go
into superposition for a moment but then
they always collapse back or maybe the
moment they're about to superpose they
pick up determinate state and then the
thought was if that happens say
consciousness is like that consciousness
never enters a superposition the moment
brain processes would be such that they
would produce a superposition of
consciousness and somehow they collapse
into a definite state right and then you
might see that as an effect of
consciousness on the physical processes
in the brain that could in principle
give you an effect of consciousness in
the physical world and then the question
is it's me ultimately turns I'm it's a
while it's a weird and speculative
picture of course but anyone's theory of
consciousness is we have been
speculative for making up old ideas from
people like that juror and and they
dropped out of favor now yeah but you
want to reexamine absolutely serve igner
and 1961 remarks on the mind-body
question is probably the locus classic
us for this people think they find the
idea hints of the idea at least in fun
Lyman and earlier in the 1970s this got
associated worth you know that dancing
wooly masters and so on at which point
physicists started running a mile lot of
some reason this yeah idea I think you
know it has been used in some
unfortunate ways but I just want to
examine this idea see if we can get on
on the table as one of the many
alternative interpretations of quantum
mechanics which has upsides and
downsides for me the question is
ultimately can you give it a good
parent mathematical dynamics that works
and is consistent with all of our
predictions if that could be done then
we can take it seriously now I should
say that the version Calvin and I
started with does have one rather
serious problem with the so called
quantum Zeno effect okay
yeah roughly the quantum Zeno effect
says if you've got some quantities that
are constantly being measured they're
always measured so they never enter into
super positions then they never change
so if you constantly measure the
position of a particle it'll never move
I can see where this would be a problem
yes if consciousness is if consciousness
is such that it's constantly never
entering into a superposition it's at
least as if consciousness is never being
measured is always being measured which
means the consciousness can never change
so for example if you start out with an
early universe with no consciousness
then consciousness will never get a
chance to come into existence the moment
there's a little glimmer of
consciousness it's going to like it's
gonna snap back right only one tiny
little low amplitude part of the wave
function will they be consciousness and
with probability one it will snap back
turn no consciousness the consciousness
can never evolve furthermore you can
never wake up from a nap you'll never
get there there'll be little branches
that develop consciousness they'll snap
back to unconscious with good world now
I like it yeah let's go on forever so
okay this was a small small problem for
the initial simplest version of the
theory which we're now trying to work
this into a negative result paper called
Zeno goes to Copenhagen okay raising the
Zeno effect is a problem for a class of
interpretations nearby but then the
question is kinda was there reversion of
this you can make work or it won't
suffer from this Zeno problem we've been
playing around with probabilistic
versions and versions where
consciousness super poses for a while
and collapses back and I'd say we
haven't exactly solved the problem yet
but I think there's a there's at least
an interesting class of interpretations
here worth taking seriously if you are
inclined to take consciousness seriously
enough for all quantum mechanics there's
enough of a mess that it's worth trying
not like there's any interpretations
that
is free of problems oh right if there's
something here that a gives you a
perfectly adequate quantum mechanics and
B allows a role for consciousness in the
physical world and that would at least
be reason to take the view seriously and
if you are a property dualist if you
believe in mental properties as well as
physical properties of stuff does that
have implications for questions like
artificial intelligence or you know
consciousness on a computer yeah I think
it doesn't have immediate implications I
mean some people think that if you're a
property dualist you should think that
computers won't be conscious to me
that's kind of all I mean we're
biological systems who who are with
brains and somehow we're conscious so
why should silicon be any worse off than
than say brains I mean it almost seems
like a weirdly materialist idea to
privilege the the you know things made
of DNA everything's made of silicon
right why should that make a difference
I think so jewelle ism is just neutral
on the question the kind of property
dualism I like a fairly you know
scientific naturalistic property dualism
with fundamental laws of nature I think
it's gonna come down to are the
properties of matter to get connected to
consciousness in our theory of
consciousness are they gonna be more
like specific biological properties or
are they going to be more like
computational or informational
properties if it's something like
Chinese integrated information that
gives you a consciousness it looks like
that could be present just as much in a
silicon system as in a biological system
so in the work I've done at least I've
I've tried to argue that it's really the
computational properties of matter that
are relevant to to consciousness or the
informational properties if that's the
case then an AI system will be able to
do the job just as well and in principle
we could even replace our neurons you
know one of the time the biological
neurons by silicone prosthetic neurons
if they work well enough we'll be left
with a functionally identical system and
I would actually argue that that
function identical system is going to
retain the same consciousness throughout
the alternative would be to say that
consciousness feeds evades away or
disappears but like that gives rise to
all kinds of problem right
and then if before I was asking if I'm
sure I'm not a zombie this leads us to
ask if we are sure that we're not a
computer simulation right hmm this is a
this is one of the great problems of
philosophy
I mean Descartes said how do we know
that there's an external world how do
you know you're not being fooled by an
evil demon who's merely producing
experiences in you as of an external
reality when all of this is just being
generated by the demon now the
simulation idea it's a wonderful 21st
century version of of Descartes I mean
as illustrated by movies like The Matrix
I'm still a fan of the depiction of this
movie and they're in the matrix that
really I think got quite a lot of this
right how do you know you're not living
in a computer simulation that is the
computer simulation is playing the role
of the evil demon running a model of a
world feeding your brain experiences
when in fact you think and you think
you're in an ordinary physical reality
but in fact you're in this
computer-generated reality and the
people who wrote movies like The Matrix
they say if this is the case then you're
basically living a life of illusion and
deception and that the relevant world
and none of it is a is real which is
exactly what Descartes thought about
evil demon hypothesis oh I'd be thinking
about this lately and I I do take the
simulation idea seriously I think
there's nothing we know with certainty
that rules out the idea we're in a
computer simulation the philosopher Nick
Bostrom was actually given a statistical
argument that we should take it very
seriously that we are in a simulation
roughly the idea is that any
sufficiently intelligent population will
have the capacity to create lots and
lots of computer simulations of whole
populations so as long as they go ahead
and and use their abilities and create
computer simulations then most the
majority of beings in the universe will
be simulated beings and not unstimulated
beings and then the thought is we'll
just do the do the math
do the statistics 99.9% of beings in the
universe are simulated including a whole
bunch were just like me what are the
odds that I'm one of the lucky ones at
Ground Zero the 0.1% so you might say I
should be 999 out of 99.9 percent
confident that I'm a simulated being no
you can raise issues with the reasoning
here and there one question is would a
simulated being be conscious some people
I don't know they are not conscious
they'll be zombies if so the fact that
I'm conscious so I'm not in a simulation
you think you're conscious go ahead but
but but at least but that's not gonna
help me because I'm I'm released on
record as thinking that it yes simulated
system an AI system could be just as
conscious as a biological system so I
think all those beings in computer
simulations may well be conscious maybe
it's only 50% okay even if it's only 50%
likely they're conscious then that still
should give a big dose of probability to
hypothesis that I'm in a simulation so
that's not gonna help so I think it's
actually possible that you know I do I
can't rule out that we're in a
simulation where I where I want to get
off the boat there was this idea that
simulations are illusions right that
simulations aren't real I think we could
be we could be in a world which is a
simulation but if so that doesn't mean
that you know there's no tables and
chairs in the world around us there's no
matter it's all an illusion I think what
we should say is instead yeah we're in a
world with tables and chairs and matter
and we've made it if we're in a
simulation then if we discover we're in
a simulation we'll have made a
surprising discovery about what tables
and chairs are made of they're all
ultimately made of say information and
computational processes at the next
level down which may ultimately be
realized in processes in the next
universe at but importantly it's all
still real it's not like as they can't
thought of world where nothing around
you exists yes the world around me
exists it just has a surprising nature
and this actually connects nicely to the
ideas about structural realism we were
talking about before that really physics
tells you about the structure of the
world it doesn't tell you ultimately but
what that
structure is made up of if we're in a
simulation it turns out the structure is
exactly the mathematical structure of
our reality may be exactly as physics
says it's just that it's all implemented
or realize on a computer in the next
universe up
so yeah the structure of physics is real
so the electrons are still real they're
just ultimately electrons made of bits
made of whatever is fundamental in the
next universe up you said if we ever
find out is there any way we would ever
find out it depends how well the
simulation is made doesn't it you know
if it's like the one in the matrix where
they they gave us some potential ways
out like the red pill is very buggy code
yeah and yeah that's a dumb way to build
a simulation if you ask me unless you
want people to to escape if it's a
perfect simulation we may we may never
find out at because of that I think if
we're not in a simulation we may never
be able to prove that we're not in a
simulation because in a perfect
simulation any evidence any proof we can
get could be simulated right by being
for the same experiences so I think
we'll never get we'll never know for
sure the negative claim we're not in a
simulation it could be that if we are in
a simulation we could get some very
decisive evidence for that you know if
if the simulators suddenly move the moon
around in the sky yeah you know and
write big signals and we we look it out
to get a code we've had messages written
then they're saying hey losers you're in
a simulation then we take that to be
pretty strong as the pre-existing strong
cases of God having you've done all this
right it's not that different endings
young our programmers doing these things
exactly and people and the questions
about the question of evidence arises
for God as well I mean we could in
principle get decisive evidence that
there is a God it's very hard to get
decisive evidence that there's not a god
and you think that it's realistic to
think that we can at least imagine
simulating doing simulations that are so
good that a multiplicity of intelligent
conscious creatures exist there in our
simulators simulations I think so in
principle I mean I don't see it's just
about really of computer power and of
you know what you know might be know the
laws of physics well enough presumably
we could set up a universe with
boundary conditions like which are
allowable boundary conditions for
universe like us set up the differential
equation simulators on our on our maybe
it will need to be a quantum computer to
be especially to get the quantum
mechanics right but then I don't see why
I'm principled you couldn't get maybe
it'd be hard to get a universe as
complex as our universe yeah I would
have to be less so that every could be
less right yeah if our universe is
finite has say you know 1 billion units
of complexity then we can't simulate
something with 1 million units of
complexity but maybe something with you
know 1 million units of complexity just
to not detect the universe yeah too much
and of course where if we are and the
enormous universe that we seem to be in
now with enormous resources that seems
to probably it all have resources to be
able to simulate some pretty complicated
universes without without too much
trouble in principle these kinds of
scenarios whether it's Descartes or
simulations or whatever I mean can we or
God creating the universe can we apply
some kind of anthropic reasoning here
and ask you know if this were the case
would that have some implications for
what the universe would look like and
then ask it does or does not look like
that like I've certainly said if you
want to depend on if you want to argue
that the fine-tuning in the universe of
certain fundamental physics parameters
that therefore allows for the existence
of life is evidence for the existence of
God then you should be consistent in
that argument and point out that there
are other things about our universe that
look wildly unlike you would expect if
the point of the universe existing was
for our life to exist can we say similar
things about the purported simulators
yeah I mean you might worry that most
simulations are gonna have certain
properties and that our universe dazzl
doesn't have those properties I mean one
thing about the universe is its enormous
it seems to be enormous a big it's so
complicated why would you waste your
time it doesn't if you're gonna be
making simulations you might think most
simulations are gonna be a whole lot
smaller and
for for many purposes why would
simulators be a the generating universe
is quite as big and as complex as we are
you might think you're average of course
whatever you do make an universe like
that like us it's gonna involve a whole
bunch of people making simulations of
universes which are simpler in turn
universes which is simpler in turn more
and more of those ever simpler universes
so you might think that actually most
universe isn't gonna be very very so
exactly that's what I would think yeah I
might have heard Sean Carroll making in
the past at some point and then so they
have the very fact that we're in a
complicated universe is gonna be at
least some reason to disfavor the
simulation simulation hypothesis now of
course
so to go there's a little bit of back
and forth here one could respond to that
by saying well we don't know the
universe is big we see galaxies in the
sky really we see photons that have
recently reached us we don't see the
galaxies themselves maybe there's
nothing more than a few million light
years away and it's all just set up to
make us think that but then when some
sort of skeptical nightmare maybe it's
just like everything out to the solar
system yeah we've actually sent probes
out to the people to you know to other
planets and so on so the earth
I don't know I'm pre I'm thinking it's
gotta be hard just to simulate like a
like New York City because there's so
many people leaving New York City all
the time and coming back and the news
from the outside the very least you're
gonna have to have a pretty detailed
simulation of the rest of the earth to
keep all that right use pay through the
TV and everything going but once you
move outside the earth against at least
a bit easier maybe it's like maybe the
moon is just I mean if we least kind of
need a fairly detailed simulation of the
moon because of the role it plays in our
lives but maybe beyond a certain point
you can run a very cheap simulation
maybe beyond Pluto we've just got a very
cheap simulation of the rest of the
universe every now and then maybe the
science maybe the simulators say hi
they've just made a new discovery
they've placed on a new a new form of a
new way to monitor star
they're looking a little bit closer
these exoplanets and maybe they they
scramble and they come up with some new
data for us but maybe that's gonna turn
out to be much easier to run a cheaper
simulator it doesn't doesn't even saying
these words make you think that maybe
this is not the world we live in that
this is not the wall that that the these
are all kind of arguments against living
in a simulation just our universe does
look way bigger than it does you can
imagine things the simulators could do
but why are they going to all this
trouble I think it's quite possible
though that the weather I don't know
whether our universe is infinite yeah it
was quite possible that the basic
universe is infinite and maybe you know
the next unit in the next universe up
they have infinite resources yeah it
turns out that simulating a large finite
universe is no problem at all in fact
they can simulate infinite universes
because in an infinite universe you'll
have the resources for to simulate an
infinite number of infinite universes
without without problems so as long as
we don't fall into the trap of thinking
that the next universe up has to be just
like ours they don't think all bets are
off
and are there ethical implications for
this or are there implications of this
idea for how we should think about
ethics number one should we think about
ethics in our world differently if we're
simulations and should we worry about
making simulations with conscious
creatures and treating them well I think
that the ethics of our world didn't be
affected drastically by this anymore
that has to be affected drastically by
the theistic hypothesis the word a
universe with a God we're still
conscious beings living our lives treat
other people well make sure they have by
and large positive conscious experiences
rather than the negative ones maybe we
need to think about the impact of our
actions on the people in the next
universe up but since we don't really
know what those what that impact is it's
you might say there's a self interest
comes into this after all if we want to
live on the religious hypotheses people
modify their behavior greatly in order
they can live forever we might want to
you know make sure the simulators keep
us around I mean there's open the
possibility of natural life right if
we're in the simulation yeah I mean
maybe a quite naturalist just as the
simulation hypothesis here has a very
naturalistic version of God it could
have a naturalistic version of an
afterlife we already see in TV shows
like black mirror
that you know people come to the end of
their lives and they upload into a into
a simulation and keep going keep going
that way my bread
Ian banks is culture novels I haven't
actually I should oh okay you certainly
should because part of it it's it's a
small part except for one novel where it
plays a major role but there's this idea
that yeah they do simulations all the
time
there are conscious consciousnesses
agents in the simulations and therefore
the intergalactic organization has
passed laws you can't end it the
simulations because that would be
genocide but then there's certain very
very bad civilizations that actually
turn them into hells where they torture
the AIS that didn't behave in the right
way so I think the ethical questions
absolutely get a grip once we start
thinking about creating our own
simulations and I'm sure any number of
people are going to be tempted just once
you've got the capacity to start up a
copy of Sim universe running on our
iPhone and maybe get a thousand copies
up and running and see what happens
overnight run the entire history of this
universe gather the statistics could be
useful for scientific purposes could be
useful for like marketing purposes
predicting what products gonna do well
could just be tricky to go there because
oh for sure you want to you want to test
your different products and see which
iPhone is gonna write is gonna sell the
best for sure but yeah I think the
ethical issues really are enormous
you're gonna be creating you're gonna be
creating universes with billions of
billions trillions maybe infinitely many
people and each of which is living a is
living a life as a conscious being and
if their lives of suffering then we've
done something horrific and if their
lives of pleasure then maybe we've maybe
we've done something good but yet people
talk about did God create when creating
us create the rest of all possible
worlds why was there so much evil well
maybe God created many different
universes all the ones that had a net
balance of positive experiences over
negative experiences turned out by
creating all those worlds and somehow
there was a net positive in creating
them well we're gonna face questions
like this too maybe if you want to
create
experimental wolves with a suffering you
can only do that when there's a net
balance of positive experiences in your
in your simulations to make up for it
even then someone's gonna say well you
could have created an even better world
with a bit less suffering and a bit more
and a bit more pleasure or fulfillment
or satisfaction so didn't you do
something immoral by creating creating
this board I think we're gonna have to
face all those questions they're not
gonna have easy answers okay speaking of
easy answers two last questions for you
David one is you're working on a book do
I know it's well advanced but we can
prime our audience to be ready you want
to say anything about what the book will
be sure yeah the the focus of the book
is very much the set of issues we've
been talking about for the last few
minutes about simulations and about
virtual reality my working title
probably won't be the final title but
the working titles reality 2.0
artificial worlds and the great problems
of philosophy and it's all about
exploring philosophical problems like
our knowledge of the external world and
the nature of reality through this
through the idea of artificial or
virtual reality so yeah are we in a
matrix that's one of them but also I
really wanted to develop my own
philosophical line which is virtual
reality simulated reality is a genuine
kind of reality it's not a fake right
for our second class we are it's a
perfectly respectable way for a world to
be and I think this is relevant not just
for a way out
speculation science fiction scenario is
like we're living in a simulation but
very practical scenarios like the
virtual reality technology that's being
developed today things like you know the
oculus rift where people enter into into
virtual worlds and start spending more
and more of their time there it's easy
to imagine 50 or 100 years in the future
we are going to we're all going to be
spending a lot of our time in these
virtual worlds and the questions going
to arise is that can you actually lead a
meaningful life there yeah and is this
is it enlightening sure there's a
meaningful question this is aimed at a
popular audience or professional
philosophers or both I would say both
but I'm
but absolutely trying to make it as
accessible as possible so anyone can
anyone can read this book you have
leaders so you can do that yeah I hope
they weren't revoke it but yes it's
meant to be both introducing a whole lot
of philosophical ideas but also putting
forward a substantive philosophical view
of my own but roughly this view that
virtual reality is a first-class reality
across all of these domains
I think it has bearing on the grateful
grateful esophageal problems how do we
know there's an external world de cartes
problem
it has bearings on the question of the
relationship between mind and body and
has bearing on these ethical questions
about you know what makes a meaningful
and valuable existence or life of the
cloud so I think it's actually a way to
come at some of the deepest
philosophical problems just through this
lens of justice thinking about
artificial intelligence turns out to
shed light on many questions about the
human mind I think thinking about
artificial reality is turns out to shed
life and all kinds of questions about
the actual natural reality we find
ourselves in so that's what I'm trying
to do and the last question is Tom
Stoppard swimming favorite living
playwrights playwrights period he wrote
a play called the heart problem how does
it feel to have a phrase you coined
become the title of a Tom Stoppard oh I
was very pleased I think actually was my
friend Dan Dennett who sent me an email
he written this in an article and said
hey there's a Tom Stoppard play coming
out called the hot promise of great
because this got something to do with
consciousness but it turns out it does
and I've actually gotten to know Tom
Stoppard a little as a result of this
process he put on it had its American
opening in in Philadelphia a couple of
years ago maybe about a year ago the
Wilmeth era in Philadelphia and I went
down there and did an event with Tom
with the two of us talking onstage about
the hard problem of consciousness the
play is very interesting I'm not
convinced it's actually about
consciousness at its root it's about a
much broader set of questions some of
which involve consciousness some of
which involve God some of which involve
value and effect in this discussion
it sort of emerged that it's not that it
seemed to me that the problem that was
really generating things for Tom was not
the problem of consciousness but the
problem of value hmm how can you have
the experience of some things being
better than others of life being
meaningful love of sorrow versus versus
happiness of course that's very deeply
connected to consciousness but I
suggested to him that really his heart
problem was the problem of value and he
agreed he said yes thank you I think
maybe that's what's really moving me the
hi it's another famously heart valve
Alvin okay it's not the hard problem but
they're all mixed up I mean you got to
write the best play right that's even
I'm what I'm an adviser for Hollywood
movies about science that the goal is to
make the best movie not to be the best
science documentary but the the play is
about to open actually here in here in
New York at the at the Lincoln Center so
I don't know have another round of all
of this coming up actually the last I
don't wanna give away any spoilers about
the play but at certain point they
mentioned that the main character goes
to work with a professor at NYU whose
ideas are said to be in demonstrable and
very people have asked me whether that's
whether that's me I'm actually fairly
confident that it's not I think it's my
colleague Tom negging is Dominick
omnigul who what does it like to be a
bat yes and he's the he's the professor
at simply the label of being a
philosopher whose ideas have been called
non demonstrable is doesn't doesn't
really narrow things down too much oh
yeah my was talking about this with my
colleague Ned block there's three of us
at NYU who work on the philosophy of
consciousness and we decided that the
philosopher in question surely couldn't
be neither of us because our ideas are
demonstrable absolutely right all right
David Chalmers thanks so much for being
on the podcast thanks it's been a
pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]